bonsoir messieurs merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur herbst et france
première question pour vous général
gérard ollivier pardon les fraudes
invoquée par un par donald trump vous
par estelle crédible alors c'est bien
gérald avec avec un l
le problème si vous voulez c'est que il
y à un véritable historique de fraude
aux états unis en dépit de ce que
beaucoup de gens dit vous avez une fine
tank américain qui s'appelle bill gates
foundation qui a créé une liste où ils
ont répertorié plus de 1300 cas de
fraude au cours des dernières années
donc il y a un historique de fraude dans
les élections
on sait que par le passé dans certaines
élections présidentielles notamment
celle de 1960 il y avait également eu
des instances de fraude dans deux états
clé de l'époque qui était l'illinois et
le texas
donc évoqué des fraudes c'est
parfaitement légitime
par ailleurs vous avez en pennsylvanie
malheureusement un système qui favorise
le doute et qui favorise la fraude parce
que lorsque vous acceptez des bulletins
au delà de la date du scrutin et qui
n'est pas nécessaire que ces bulletins
pour un cachet de la poste indiquant
qu'ils ont été mises au courrier avant
la date du scrutin
quand vous permettez à certains
bulletins d'être validé sans
vérification de signature
et même si mia signature sur le bulletin
ne correspond pas à la signature dont
dispose la commission électorale sur ses
registres d'inscription vous créez le
soupçon d'irrégularité donc les les
demandes de donald trump sont
parfaitement légitimes d'autant plus
qu'elles vont être examinés par des
cours de justice qui sont libres de les
rejeter si elle estime qu'elles sont un
food of infondées mais le président est
parfaitement dans son droit de demander
non seulement des recomptages dans
certains états mais des vérifications si
il n'ya eu des irrégularités
pour l'instant c'est ainsi que le
système est supposé fonctionner il y à
la pennsylvanie
ni qui est donc demandé trois jours
supplémentaires pour comptabiliser les
votes qui arrivé trois jours après par
par courrier la cour suprême a dit que
c'était valide
randy orandi aloses que pensez vous de
ces accusations proférées par donald
trump qui a d'ailleurs été censurée sur
les médias américains hier soir
pourquoi vous considérez que c'est des
accusations aujourd'hui on a même les
directeurs de la commission fédérale qui
dit que les allégations de fraude
apparaît sondés il a déclaré ça
aujourd'hui pour vos nouvelles
je ne sais pas si vous êtes au courant
la lesbian enquête et quittons cours
dont les comptes aider l'ukraine à payer
venizel et comptent aider l'ukraine sur
la disparition à et la suppression à des
bulletins de vote par les personnels de
d&d l'élection donc les élèves beac est
impliqué dans l'anc est assassin niveau
déterminé cia y accomplir est en quête
ça veut dire qu'il ya déjà des normes de
preuves qui ont permis de faire
commencer l'enquète ils font pas d'
enquête s'il ya pas un début de preuve
et un commencement de preuve
donc il s'il vous plaît qu'on veut pas
médias de langue ils y perdent on
retombe avec des histoires
ils ont déjà un commencement peuvent
donc ils estiment qu'elle se bat là pour
ouvrir une enquête
deuxième point est en train to see qui a
été déposée par le républicain elle
trempe auprès de la procure deux
républiques d nevada il estime qu'il y a
presse 10000 un bulletin de vote qui ont
été acceptés comptabilisés à pour des
non résidents d'une part aussi vous
devrez nous tes rappeler à votre chère
téléspectateurs qui ont par l'onp est
venue de sept huit mille bulletins de
vote les différences entre les deux
candidats donc on parle vous voyez si un
incident ils ont même estimé que ça peut
être entre plusieurs dizaines de
milliers le fait qu'ils ont laissé les
personnes à l'extérieur qu'on les les
observateurs républicains étaient
empêchés d'entrer et vérité et contrôler
les dépouillements des votes donc on est
vraiment dans cette situation et
georgi indifférence des quais mille voix
voyez donc si demain il ya une
contestation et sa porte ce qu'emile
vois ça peut changer complètement
l'élection donc il faut être les pros
sérieux et pas dit ok c'est c'est
infondé par rapport à ça c'est dieu qui
il ya de la matière il faut faire une
enquête
et ça ira devant le tribunal et de la
police les billets et les tribunaux vont
l'apprécier
personne ne s'étant fondée on dit
simplement qu'il faut attendre
évidemment et que des enquêtes sont en
cours
j'irai le vivier finalement serré les
résultats très serrés qui font que
effectivement la fraude ou pas on devra
attendre
évidemment toutes les procédures
judiciaires pourraient pourrait changer
la donne de ces élections
oui alors à ce stade je vous avoue c'est
quand même c'est très avancé et c'est
vrai que joe biden est dans une position
extrêmement favorable néanmoins avant de
prononcer de dire que ce café nancy
pelosi par exemple aujourd'hui ça me
paraît prématuré
je crois que attendons que les
différents recours soit passer par des
cours de justice qu'elle est suivi leurs
processus parce qu'il peut y avoir appel
et c'est vrai qu'on peut monter de cour
d'appel en cour suprême d'état voire en
cour suprême fédérale
donc attendons que le pouvoir judiciaire
fasse son travail
et après on pourra juger conclure et
dire qui est le président élu est
légitimement élu et il faudra à ce
moment là cela il faudra que l'amérique
parviennent à se réconcilier
moi ce qui ce qui me fait très peur dans
ce processus c'est que il ya toute une
partie de l'électorat et rappelons que
donald trump a réuni lui aussi prêt de
70 millions d'électeurs il ya un vrai
mouvement derrière lui et un mouvement
qui avait beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé et ces gens
l'ont vu mener la nuit du mardi au
mercredi
et puis soudain on leur a appris que le
dépouillement était interrompu dans un
certain nombre d'états ils sont allés se
coucher et quelques heures plus tard
quand ils ont ouvert la télé pour savoir
où on en doutait ils se sont aperçus que
les chiffres avaient considérablement
changé et les chiffres n'ont cessé de
changer depuis en allant
systématiquement
même direction c'est à dire un avantage
du candidat john dryden perception
inévitablement être très négative et je
me plais midi elle explique par le fait
que ce sont des votes par correspondance
et que donc ça me c'est exact mais si
vous voyez ce qui s'est passé en floride
l'écart des votes par correspondance en
floride n'a pas été du tout ce qu'il
avait été annoncé c'est à dire qu'il y
avait beaucoup plus de républicains qui
avaient voté par courrier en proportion
de ce qu'on attendait on était sur un
apport de 6 à 4 alors qu'on avait évoqué
un rapport de 8 à 2 en faveur des
démocrates
hélas en pennsylvanie ou en géorgie on
était sur un rapport de 8 à 2 voire de 9
à 1 en pennsylvanie je crois que c'est
un rapport de 9,1 donc il est évident
que ça invite un certain questionnement
est le problème que je pose au delà de
la réalité des fraudes ou pas c'est que
la perception pour l'électorat américain
est extrêmement mauvaises et vous le
disiez dans le cas d'une élection aussi
serrée
et bien c'est là où ça pose problème et
je crois que pour la prochaine élection
il faudra vraiment que les cours
fédérales et les cours d'étape
parviennent à trouver un système qui
soit plus crédible que nos systèmes de
cette année parce que là il ya vraiment
un problème
c'est vrai que dans certains états randy
gallows il n'y a même pas besoin de deux
cases identité pour voter c'est le cas
de ces états ou aux états unis dit et
vous regardez les pinceaux venue de
votre chèque chères invitées et je le
remercie parce qu'il est très précis
dans ses c'est dit sans explication dans
l'état des peines est bénite
on a même effacé la procédure de
vérification des signatures de lord et
du contrôle des bulletins de vote
et comme vous avez expliqué que dans
certains n'ont même pas besoin de carte
d'identité pour aller voter
on est où c'est pourquoi nous des
républicains depuis le début parce que
c'est des modifications qui ont été
faits par les démocrates depuis un an et
on se pose à ses visions parce que ça
crée un risque des fraudes
et pourquoi faire ça sadio qui ont leurs
yeux du kremlin a augmenté à l'est la
confiance qu'on peut avoir dans l'ain
dans le système électoral ont réduit les
l'intégrité qui ont peu d'aidé système
électoral en faisant cela se dit ok
c'est mauvais exemple les leaders qui
seront démocrates et républicains jeudi
pas peut-être cette fois-ci c'était les
démocrates peut-être dans l'histoire
c'était un moment donné des républicains
ouvriers au guide est rond ça on n'en
sait rien les deux on peut être formulée
oui non non mais c'est ce que je vous
explique ça peut être un moment donné
dans l'histoire que ce soit à gauche que
ce soit à droite mais en tout cas ils
doivent donner l'exemple question on
passe des lois comme ça on crée des
doutes et aussi en crée des doutes sur
la validité et l'intégrité des des
élections et les résultats par la suite
et c'est pas bien pour le peuple parce
qu'après ils sont frustrés et sa peau le
rize l'époque américain le très reconnu
d'ailleurs new york post ce n'est pas
donald trump qui profèrent ces
informations c'est le new york post qui
dit qu'il ya même des morts qui ont voté
alors on ne sait pas véritablement dans
quelles proportions
mais dans un système qui est sont ces
deux surveillants l'entendez cette dame
dans le sujet dire que personne ne
pouvait passer à travers les ordinateurs
apparemment cette sinon ils n'ont pas
mis leur registre ça c'est notre système
parce qu'ils y gagnent ce ton chaque
circonscription et garde un registre des
lecteurs qui met à jour nécessairement
mais si c'est un parti qu'est un pouvoir
je dis ça peut être un ou deux dans ce
cas nous on reprocha aux démocrates
aujourd'hui il ne reproche pas
heureusement parce que je dirais la même
chose y avait un souci avec un côté
républicain on dirait de faire le même
recours
je suis pas hypocrite mais dans notre
cas on a un souci c'est dans plusieurs
registre des certaines circonscriptions
qui n'ont pas mis à jour ton qui avait
peut-être des morts il ya peut-être des
non résidents qui sont partis peut-être
il ya aussi les normes des suspects sont
inscrits et éligibles sont pas les mêmes
choses on a eu des cas ont d'étroites
qui amène enquête en 2019
un recours qui a été fait par une
association de droite qui a intervenu
il y avait quarante mille voix qui était
contestée et après
mis à jour par cette association compte
une action qu'ils avaient faite aux
quarante mille votes qui aurait peut
être concernés dans le cadre de votre
trait essentiel pour une seule ville
donc vous voyez on est en train de
parler pour le changer quelques 1000
votes pour percer venus 7,8 milles donc
quand on parle d'une ville ça peut aller
jusqu'à 48 à ce que le régime n'est pas
tenue à jour
c'est très grave la géorgie
il va recompter général de villiers est
ce que ça va être le cas pour pour les
autres états selon vous on est parti
pour un scénario
comment en 2000 avec le recomptage en
floride alors je je crois que la règle
veut que si l'écart du résultat est
inférieur à 1 % leur compte soit
obligatoire dans pratiquement tous les
états il n'y a même pas besoin de le
demander si l'écart est suffisamment
étroit
le recomptage est automatique en cas
d'un écart un petit peu plus important
il faut le demander et dans ce cas là
c'est le demandeur qui doit payer pour
le recomptage donc il est parfaitement
logique qu'en géorgie temps donné qu'on
est à 0,2 il ya un recomptage je pense
qu'il y aura également un comptage en
caroline du nord et je sais qu'il ya
déjà un recomptage en cours dans louise
consignes et au passage mais aussi et
c'est même pas finir en pennsylvanie on
n'a pas commencé parce qu'il y en aura
aussi mais pour fournir une chose c'est
que en 2016 en 2016 y avait eu un
recomptage au risque en chine après que
hillary clinton est perdue donc là rien
d'extraordinaire à l'art au contraire et
moi je suis pour ce recomptage parce que
c'est ce qui donne confiance dans le
système
et pour répondre à la deuxième partie de
votre question oui je crains
malheureusement que l'on soit parti pour
plusieurs jours plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines de mitigation
rappelons que l'élection présidentielle
est une élection au suffrage indirect
en fait là les docteurs les électeurs
ont voté pour des électeurs qui vont
siéger au sein du collège électoral
le collège électoral se réunit je crois
le 14 décembre et les états ont jusqu'au
8 décembre pour soumettre le résultat de
leur élection au collège électoral dont
la date butoir pour l'instant c'est
celle du 8 décembre est pour moi
l'équipe de donald trump continuera à
chercher à défendre sa version des faits
jusqu'au 10 décembre
que peut dire joe biden ce soir randy à
l'eau selon vous après l'allocution du
président américain qui je le rappelle a
été censuré par certains médias moi si
j'étais à sa place je resterais à sa
place parce que il n'a pas intérêt parce
que si on trouve certaines choses ça va
le discréditer donc c
j'étais dans son ventre je ne dirais pas
grand chose sur la situation je
laisserai la période la justice faire
son travail
biya et la police et on verra bien parce
que s'ils commencent à dire avant c'est
trop il va se discréditer ça c'est mon
point de vue est en tout cas vous devez
aussi on devra pellet dans le cas d'un
recomptage c'est là l'occasion les
républicains et aussi pour les
démocrates de vérifier la conformité la
régularité des chaque bulletin de vote à
nouveau donc ça va être une occasion
pour nous de vérifier tous les fronts
point qu'on a discuté est ce qu'il y
avait la bonne signature est ce que
c'est des résidents de chaque état donc
tout cela va être revue a à z pas non
l'heureux les contrées comptage qui sera
fait dans le wisconsin dont les jours j
l et caroline du nord et éventuellement
le contenu qui est là et à plusieurs
problèmes à mon avis on va y arriver
aussi
gérald olivet dans quel contexte selon
vous dans quelle ambiance
ces semaines de procédure judiciaire a
priori qui s'annonce vont-elles se tenir
écoutez les tensions ont monté et elle
monte d'un cran au fur et à mesure que
les électeurs américains attendent pour
revenir sur votre première question je
pense que que joe biden va être un petit
peu subtil dans sa communication c'est à
dire qu'il va bien se garder d' affirmer
qu'il a gagné je pense qu'il va se par
contre se montrer en présidant
exactement comme il l'avait fait il ya
48 heures adopter une posture
présidentielle et avoir un discours qui
se voudra rassembleur qui voudra que les
gens tout en faisant comprendre que il
considère qu'il a gagné ce qui n'est pas
le cas à ce stade
et c'est vrai que il devra être très
prudent sur ce qu'il dit parce que pas
plus lui que le président trempe ne
peuvent se prononcer vainqueur
jusqu'à ce que les cours et les bourgs
de l'élection leur et valider leurs
élections
néanmoins pour l'instant je dirais que
le système fonctionne et c'est tant
mieux mais il serait souhaitable à
l'avenir de faire en sorte que le
résultat d'une élection présidentielle
soient connus immédiatement parce que
pour moi ces tensions sont inutiles et
elles introduisent dans l'électorat des
doutes des frustrations
voir l comment dirais-je elle emprunte
la crédibilité du système
c'est ça qui est le vrai problème au
delà du vainqueur c est ce qu on a un
président légitime et si la moitié de
l'amérique considère que le président
n'est pas légitime
c'est pas un bon départ pour parvenir à
réunifier le pays
randy elle ose le mot de la fin ça
décrédibilise le système américain selon
vous est ce que cette élection pourrait
faire jurisprudence ou en tout cas
faudrait-il une modification de l'ordre
de l'organisation de ces élections je je
suis d'accord avec notre invité j'ai on
doit tirer délais sont d'aider cette
élection est la crédibilité du système
électoral américain
et il faut aussi à dire quel est le rôle
des états comme la pennsylvanie est
aussi la responsabilité suprême dans sa
décision d'aso mais la décision de la
cour d'appel de pennsylvanie qui a rendu
ces conditions à six a selon moi s'ils
avaient rejeté la décision
il aurait cassé la décision de la cour
suprême des pv ne sera pas là
aujourd'hui
moi je pense qu'ils auraient affirmé sa
position on n'y aura pas une mise en
cause de l'intégrité et la système
électoral mais à mon avis aura un
travail vraiment faire partie
c'était là s'est il aura pu s'affirmer
la cour suprême à ce moment là et c'est
un siège pour le cnra stratégique de la
part de la cour suprême
moi en tant qu'avocat c'est ce que je
pense et je le dis et je pense pour la
prochaine fois il faut réfléchir à cette
question
merci beaucoup et randy galop et merci à
vous chers à l'olivier d'avoir débattue
ce même si vous étiez d'accord ce soir
sur rtl france